welcome to the heavy spoilers show don't
know I'm saying that as there's no
spoilers force a habit anyway in the
wake of birds of prey in the fantabulous
emancipation of one Holly Quinn
officially being the longest title and
the lowest opening weekend of a DC EU
box office the film is changing one big
thing that is its name
from here on our warner brothers will be
marketing the movie as harley quinn
birds of prey the title has already
taken effect on multiple movie ticketing
sites across the internet and though I
doubt they will be sending out new
posters for the film this is what it
will be called from now on but will it
save the movie well I think you already
know the answer to that and to me it
just exemplifies the shortsightedness of
Warner Brothers marketing in their
recent efforts whether it's birds of
prey doctors sleep or the lego movie -
the studio's recent ventures have all
underperformed at the box office despite
being good films in their own right now
I did do a big review on the film which
you should definitely check out if you
haven't and I scored it an 8 out of 10
after re-watching the movie I stand by
that score and pretty much the majority
of the Internet is an agreement that the
film is enjoyable
so therefore the failing of the movie
has to fall at the feet of the marketing
department they seem to be content with
just putting out two trailers in the
lead up to a film and then thinking
that's the extent of what they need to
do marketing needs to go far beyond that
however and with the reach of social
media being in every aspect of our homes
these days it feels like a massive
missed opportunity to not engage with it
I bet someone just sat in a boardroom
and said well Joker was just called
Joker so maybe if we change it a Holly
Quinn it's gonna do really well come on
please please do well I don't want to
get fired it shows they're just
clutching at straws and I think we all
know that this title change won't make a
difference
Holly Quinn was all over the marketing
for the film and it's unlikely that
people didn't know that she was not only
in the movie but also its main character
perhaps WB overestimate
popularity as she has a lot of fans but
maybe not enough to carry a big foam on
her back That's not me hating her either
polly was the first comic book character
I ever got tattooed on me and I think
she definitely has the presence combined
with Margot Robbie being the star but
these movies do need established names
attached to them
there was no real cameos in the film and
none of the characters baha'i have
appeared in a movie before I had their
own successful franchise juxtaposing
this in the run-up to Suicide Squad
Warner Brothers were aware of this and
thus they put the majority of the
marketing on the Joker and also showed
in the trailer as that Batman and the
flash would be in the film pretty much
all of the run-up to the film was
focused on what crazy antics Jared Leto
was doing on set and this was what was
making headlines at the time Will Smith
was also topping the roster who carries
much more of a name than Rosie Perez I
don't think many people know who the
birds of prey are but that shouldn't
really break a movie especially if it's
good Captain Marvel was a similar sort
of film in the way that it had an
unknown female carrying the whole movie
that hadn't been attached really to any
prior releases however what was so
genius about Marvel's marketing is that
they cashed in on the fact that Avengers
endgame hype was a fever pitch and that
it's release was right around the corner
even though it was a prequel Marvel
still pushed the film heavily as
something you must see in order to
understand endgame whilst that wasn't
really the case and a lot of people
including myself left it thinking that
it didn't really tie-in that much the
marketing still convinced me it did and
got myself and many others in the cinema
birds of prey on the other hand sort of
came across like a sidequest
a stopgap for Harley before the next
Suicide Squad film and this was
exemplified by its ridiculous title
let's be honest whoever thought birds of
prey and the fantabulous emancipation of
one Harley Quinn is a good title is an
absolute [ __ ] I don't know where the
market research for this was but yeah
stupid stupid stupid to make matters
worse the birds of prey on even in the
movie that much and this definitely is a
Holly Quinn solo story that just so
happens to feature them
so again it shows that Warner Brothers
didn't really understand what they were
doing I think the fact that they are
changing the title that sums up that
they think the title is enough to make a
film popular without realizing that it
isn't people aren't suddenly gonna get
off their sofa on a Saturday to go see a
movie they weren't going to just because
it's changed its name from birds of prey
to Harley Quinn trust me everyone
already knows Harley is in the movie and
if you couldn't see from the start that
this should have been reflected in the
title - then I don't know what to say
it's too late
DC also seems to be going in two
different directions at the moment as
they have the highly successful Joker
film and the upcoming Batman one which
are both away from their main universe
and this confusion may just make some
people not care and wish to stick with
the direction that they're enjoying more
we've also got a lot of female led comic
book films popping up this year
including Black Widow and Wonder Woman
and it will be interesting to see how
their box office does I do feel like
they will perform a lot better than this
but it may potentially put Marvel off
doing that all-female Avengers movie I
don't know because I imagine that it
will have the Avengers name attached to
it still though maybe Studios will
reconsider their strategy and go back to
aiming more towards a male demographic
as that tends to be where the comic book
movies do their best males still make up
the majority of the comic book audience
and both showings I went to a
birds-of-prey probably had about an 80%
attendance by men as opposed to women
Twitter seems to be crying out for films
that have more than just straight male
leads but then when it comes down to it
whether it's Charlie's Angels terminate
a dark fate men in black or birds of
prey it just seems like the people
screaming for these movies don't
actually go and see them or they're a
vocal minority that doesn't reflect the
true standing of what audience goers
want I think in general studios need to
put more market research into their
properties as anyone could have told you
that it was a bad title no not a bad
film a movie isn't made of broken on its
name I'm also seeing on Twitter that
some people are blaming men for
birds-of-prey underperforming but this
is really a conflicted message as you're
basically saying that movie can't
succeed without men
even though you told men that this movie
wasn't for them and you didn't need them
so yeah just please make up your mind
you can't tell men not to go see it and
then blame men for not going to see it
anyway I'm not not going down that
rabbit hole I guess we will see whether
this title makes a difference at the box
office but you can probably tell which
camp I'm in
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the title change so comment below and
let me know make sure you subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
day and if you want something else to
watch we've got a great breakdown of the
film which is gonna be linked at the end
every month on the 15th we give away
free blu-rays and all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning dr. sleep
is leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on you want to support the
channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button now you can also chat to us on
our discord server link below or a
definition whitey on Twitter thanks for
making it till the end of the video
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace